Vartan Gregorian when did you get an
idea that an autobiography would work I
was in the hospital 1999 was separated
from my left kidney and at that time I
realized as I face my mortality that my
son's my friends not know about private
Gregorian the only know what public
persona so I said I'm going to write
about my life my career my childhood my
education initially is what I was
writing about the concept of an educated
person how it has changed from
Renaissance to now but it got so big my
teacher said why don't you write about
your own education so without hospital I
would not have been writing ability 45
in your biggest jobs right now you're
president Carnegie corporates prior to
that I was president of Brown University
for nine years prior to that President
your public library for eight years
prior to that Provost devo Faculty of
Arts and Science University of
Pennsylvania for eight years born in
what city born in Tabriz Iran northern
Iran of Armenian parents and left Iran
when I was 14 9 15 went to Lebanon
friend charming and Lisette with
educated what does it mean to be an
Armenian it's almost to be part of jobs
family the book of jobs are comparing my
book Jews and Armenians as being part of
the block of job always being tested
always suffering never giving up part of
it defiance part of his perseverance
part of it is fate part of it is hope
part of it is struggling to be and
become where is Armenia well that's one
of the things I had hard time finding it
is an Armenia which was one of sixteen
Soviet republics not independent Armenia
Republic but they also big diaspora
from 11th century on all over Eastern
Europe and then Western Europe then Far
East singha up to Singapore Indonesia
all over the world other than Jews and
Chinese maybe Armenians one of the most
dispersed people around the world where
they dispersed where why why well 11th
century start until the 11th century
Armenians put up when any person who
came to occupy them power the 11th
century they exchange their properties
with Byzantine Emperor to go into inside
hinterlands of Byzantine Empire in order
not to fight and that's hence started a
migration her minions first to Ukraine
and then to cry myriad in Ukraine Poland
and even hungry and elsewhere so some of
the nobility of Polish nobility and
crater from Armenians we come at them
became assimilated as Catholics we came
Catholic and become assimilated and then
during a 1890s because of Sultan Abdul
Hamid and his policies of massacres and
so forth part of our minions fled
migrated to the United States and France
and elsewhere and 1915 F drug army
general said most of remnants went to
middle eastern countries and some to
soviet russia and some of them were held
and kept by american missionaries in
America and relief headed by President
Hoover at before he became president it
would under the Soviet rule 1921 23 up
to 300,000 200 to 300,000 arming and
orphans were fed by Americans one of the
biggest relief histories in the modern
world what 100 million dollar was
collected for not only our minions but
for courage Turks and all the people who
Assyrians would suffer during World War
one on the cover of this book are two
pictures yes one is obvious it's a
picture of you
today where was that taken by the way
that was by Aaron schickler new york
public library when i retired as
president of new york public library the
other one I'm three and a half four
years old in Tara and garters holding my
socks which I had not noticed still
somebody points yeah so you were born in
Tabriz Iran yes how did your parents get
there and why did they leave our meaning
to go there well actually my parents did
not as i read in the book because our
means have been in iran some 2,500 years
the part of iranian kingdom during cyrus
and derailleurs and so forth had
armenian dynasty which were parts of
iranian dynasty Armenian language is in
the European language with many basic
words from Iranian language so they have
been always there but they have been
displaced from where they have been
several times sell drugs sometimes big
some time at work amends some farmer
tatars but always there has been an
Armenian community in Iran some 2,000
years so my family I could not determine
whether there were Alzheimer's or 16th
century or 15th century imports or 19th
century because they were mostly from
peasant villages that migrated to tabriz
so I had no veo reconstructing their
history but it sold in your life who
were you closest to as an account my
mother died when I was six and a half
years old she was 26 and my maternal
grandmother brought me up she was a
peasant woman illiterate but one of the
wisest person she had tremendous role in
bringing me up and my sister and she was
a extraordinary person she had seven
children she'd lost all of them to
various not plague as much as typhus and
sad all kinds of other diseases during
World War one and some during World War
two always lack of medicine lack of
doctors and so forth resulted in their
demise but she
I had us only as her sole survivors my
sister and I so she devoted herself to
bring us up the right way as a matter of
fact I write in the book that I was
allergic to all authority except hers
she tamed me through love and also
punishment what was your relationship
with your father my father was an
absentee father because in an extended
family which my family was we called my
maternal grandmother mother and my
paternal grandfather father I never
called my father father and my mother
when she was alive as mother one we call
the shoe shake my mother and my father
Samuel and he was used to if he had a
graduate of American high school Lebanon
immoral high school in not level in
tabriz Iran and they work for
anglo-iranian oil company away so my
grandmother brought us up practically
until my father got remarried remember
11 of 12 and we had the stepmother I
know you're right about moving for
school to Lebanon it was that the first
time he never left the country first on
anybody my family left country left Iran
I mean voluntarily let's say this way
first one to leave a country and first
one to live for so far usually we went
to caucuses but all the way to
Mediterranean never and was first timers
why Lebanon when I was 30 didn't have a
as a matter fact I could sum up my life
has been a collection of strangers who
have helped me people complete strangers
when I was 13 and have a French wise
counsel go list belonging to go list
party Charles the ghost party had come
to tabriz to open a French consulate and
he became ill and I visit my friend
whose home he was staying he jokingly
said you're a smart kid what are you
doing here why don't you go to PT Perry
namely Beirut Lebanon I said I have no
money how could I go I'll take care of
it said
so I believed him but he was joking or
not it didn't matter I believed him and
suddenly there will.i.am he had written
three letters 12 French security chief
Lebanese security chief called in LaHood
went to a hotel Hotel Dukes and went to
a French Armenian they say and then
somehow my father was shocked that I'm
ready to leave he said if you can get
your own passport you can leave so I
spend a year and it's a long story but I
got my own passport and then came the
final scene where my father said there's
one other hurdle your grandmother you
need his permission knowing fully well
I'm sure that she'll never let me go
because I was solved male survivor in
her family and it was a big family
gathering where my father and others
made a passionate speeches why I should
not leave they my grandmother the moment
great moment said go and become a man so
I arrived very root with fifty dollars
with three letters without knowing
French English or Arabic I only knew
some Russian perishin Turkish and
Armenian Eastern dialect are being so I
went to see the high school principal a
perfectly german-style professor with a
monocle goatee impeccably dressed and he
asked me three devastating questions you
know French no you know English not in
Arabic know the of money know what are
you doing here I don't know I was sent
here so I was given one year probation
Lee time to learn french and threw
against rangers one copy editor of
Lauria and great french newspaper of
lebanon was paraplegic a little bit and
the urban planner took upon themselves
to teach me french saturdays and sundays
the copy editor and mondays tuesdays and
thursdays the urban planner who was
playing her poker
and bridge in some clubs and you come to
the club during intermission or my spare
time I'll teach you so within a year
with great struggle I learned French so
I was accepted to Lisa and the rest is
history talking your book if I remember
correctly there were weekends where he
didn't have a food yes how long did that
go on and when why did enjoy food well
when i arrived in Beirut I had assumed
that the hotel I was staying will be for
free I was that naive and after two
weeks i was given my bill i did not have
money to pay so i took what they were
belongings I had to sell in the market
and one of the teachers of the college
Armenian saw me he was scandalized so he
contacted the Armenian reliefs a Red
Cross and they found their restaurant
that for five and a half dollars or six
dollars a month would feed me morning
lunch and dinner but not over the
weekends our weekends were very tough
troublesome period because I used to get
angry at my stomach for being unfaithful
to me Frank lots of water and went to
church hoping that some of my classmates
will be in church in parents who will
invite me for luncheon and so forth and
read a lot fantasized a lot and slept a
lot or its killed a hunger but that
ended after the same new principle of
high school came college opinion was
last prime minister of independent of
Armenia independent Armenia 1920 and he
became director of the school and his
eyesight was not good so he made me his
second pair of eyeglasses so I became
his secretary assistant and then there
was a boarding school then I moved in
worldly school and then survived every
year in his name again was Simone rotten
brat see on any you need if I remember
you dedicate the book to him like this
and others yes
what was it like working for him and
yeah how old were you I I was by then 19
yes that's it 1921 pictures i was 21 i
work for him between ages of 19 to 21 no
actually what was that 18 to 21 34 years
over korea and he was a brilliant man
from socialist nationally socialist
Russian tradition cadet party
constitutional Democrats and socialist
revolutionaries and so forth who knew
Kerensky very well was closed so I
received private tutorials from him on
the one hand on history of Russia
Armenia international socialism
zhangzhou res and all the figures which
were fascinating at the same time I did
all his correspondence private
correspondence he was the one who in
assists was instrumental in sending me
three United States so if I figure right
here born in 1935 this has been about 19
56 56 7 you're speaking what languages
at this point are being in that swamp
Turkish in the province Persian at
school Russian at school then Arabic
colloquial in Beirut French and English
how many of those languages can you
still speak only three or four Armenian
French English understand Russian and
Stan the Arabic i mention a persian
understand but in terms of writing now
it's very hard to write so you're you
mentioned quite often and you were
headed to new york public library that
you love books you love reading when did
you start that when i was at home I
astonished me that my father was
graduate of America memorial high school
and he did have written it tracked on
feminism they had no books at home and I
was choir boy altar boy but then I was
suddenly
recruited to be a page in our minyan
library and that saved me because the
books became kind of my instruments of
liberation and when I was 11 12 years
old I start reading already novels
anything I could lay my hands on
including the only book we had that one
two books actually added on one was I
could not read English it was a second
secondary high school world history book
in English and the other one was the
Bible in vernacular Armenian and I read
the Bible many times I didn't understand
many of it except the war is somebody
killed and has somebody else killed and
so for the New Testament had no appealed
to me because there was no action but
all Testament I read several times but
then I found the world of literature
harmony literature French literature in
translation in English literature in
translation including by the way 1912
work translated in vermillion moscow
self-made men which included Andrew
Carnegie so ironic that I read about the
undercard they give Fulton and this all
self-made men in modern history in
Armenian in tabriz Iran and the books
just provide me solace isolation but
also great joy create their whole new
world for me open my horizons I called
it a kind of helicopter that took me out
of the village gave me a new life April
spent on your own I heard on your own
nobody said in your family you should
read no my only one who encouraged me to
go to school was my illiterate
grandmother because she knew the value
of education with her family enabled me
to Zion maybe family of scribes so she
always took great pride that she was
coming from a literate part of family
tradition even though she was literate
and she insisted that all their children
have to be educated and certainly
grandchildren that we educated but also
one or two teachers of mine in the
elementary school just their tails there
it just fascinated me as a matter fact I
always remember the smell of the new
book
new textbook when it came every year
eagerly cleaning the whole book rather
than waiting for First World lesson I
first lesson I read a which may be still
I remember the galaxy until now it was
about the illiterate co goes to a
pharmacy to buy eyeglasses and so what
kind of eyeglass you did reading times
first you have to know how to read I
remember before you get I glasses it
started that time and then teachers read
books and then I found in the library
wonderful books um I understood some I
did not but also i found an elderly lady
who had bound books on french literature
all in Armenian by the way and Persian I
read both languages because in 17th
century there are two Armenian
monasteries were created Catholic
monasteries one in Venice and the other
in Vienna and they translated
practically entire classical Greek Latin
and French and Italian and German
literature in Armenian including
American missionaries with translated
many works from English into our minyan
so the whole tradition of european
russian literature available to me in
our binion some very complicated war MPs
and the curry night not understand what
the fuss was about others of course very
fascinating maxim gorky is mothers and
others so when did you even think about
coming to the united states and why i
was when i was desperate for funds in
lebanon our minyan relief society of
Brazil San Paulo came to my help first
time I got the fellowship that would
allow me to buy clothes and books and so
forth with the hope that when I finish
high school advanced on the top of it
advanced Armenian studies I'll go to San
Paulo to become director of Armenian
high school in San Paulo Brazil as a
matter fact I took two weeks of
Portuguese
but then Vlad seein decided that collage
Armenian should have an English American
also orientation so he sent three four
students abroad and I was one of them
and my high school teacher whom we
called the sir he filled my applications
I want to Stanford one to Berkeley only
California because mr. Watson you bought
Kerensky and Hoover Institution he
wanted me to be in California and then
the Stanford accepted send his admission
airmail California sent his admission
surface mail so ended up at Stanford and
private universities are the public even
though I did not know the difference
total tuition and room and board and so
was seven hundred fifty dollars in 1956
where'd you get it khaleej Armenian gave
the fellowship for two years for two
years to you if you do have exam to
study English instead I studied history
instead of four years I finished in two
years ba and then I finished my PhD
exams in history and humanities also in
two years so I caught up with my age but
when I give Stanford as a freshman I was
21 23 years old he's 12 Act I sit in the
back of the room so he would think I'm a
graduate student rather than a freshman
I was so proud that I was assigned to
take speech and drama 101 rather than
English one which old freshman had to do
it so I wrote home that unlike others
I'm taking speech and drama wonder one
who ever had device that number was very
smart because one day I realized that
everybody in the classroom of foreign
students and instructor worldly tannin
Maxwell I still remember his name from
Hamilton Air Force Base whose specialty
was speech therapy so I did not even
know had an accent till I heard myself
1956 demonstrating on location of
hungarian revolution against Soviets
when they interviewed me I thought there
was something wrong with the red
you I tried to turn it I did not realize
the diet an accent at the time but
that's well so a bib at this time you're
twenty graduated from Stanford by the
time 1958 2620 no 24 and language
American Society there's a marriage in
there somewhere yes at the Stanford I
met my future wife current wife there
was 100 anniversary of translational
Rubaiyat Omar Khayyam and trusted by
future old and there was a huge major
cultural event Iran mounted in San
Francisco legion of honor and I took the
only or the most serious girl I knew
since I was head of student by the
International I did not want to be
humiliated myself before my countrymen
in a Iranian Iranian so I took her to
this great event the Irish Milo had
composed a piece on the occasion Stephen
spender was there from London to discuss
the life of Fitzgerald edward teller
gave a brilliant speech one atomic
theory Omar Khayyam there are plenty of
champagne dancing and so forth at the
end of the evening consul general of
Iran who later became minister of
culture of Iran magic rehema ask me in
Persian who is this beautiful blonde and
I told him in Persian she's wonderful
one of these days who knows I may even
marry her and then she turned the he
turned to her so congratulations when
are we getting married I almost died I
sobered up she was graduating in 10 days
this was made 2819 59 58 she was grown
all 59 she was graduating in 10 days and
so we drove
silently it's back to staff with both of
us sobered up and I said what was that
talk about marriage that one of these
days when I finish my PhD when I find a
job who knows I may even ask you to
marry you me and so forth trying to
change the subject or and you've said if
you ask the answer is yes and I said
already did so we got engaged that night
and then a year later we got married 43
years ago Claire is her first name was
her last name Russell where was she from
Tenafly New Jersey what did the family
think when you showed up on the doorstep
family had not heard of me she called
her mother said mother am engaged jail
dear no engaged to whom and not me
Indian know in Armenian is he a
christian yes and then a week later I
met their family in Oakland and thank
God I drove them the wrong way what up
hill in San Francisco traffic coming us
over they all were so traumatized they
all bonded with me so we came very good
family they became my family in America
when he wrote your autobiography energy
approach it how long ago did you start
it the hardest one was about life about
my childhood my father and my stepmother
and so forth you're coming from a
traditional society you don't write
about your family affairs as a matter
fact in the book I read about my
grandmother is saying the reason houses
are four walls in order to keep all the
family affair family news inside not out
so that was the difficult one I took me
two years but that collected everything
as in a rat like a rat pack I have all
my copy books from high school all my
copy books from Stanford all my notes
letters and so forth including one or
two Diaries that had kept and therefore
it was easy many ways because I did not
have to go through the research because
I had kept chronologically and topically
menu of this and you'd written before
what were your other books I've written
history of modernization of
modern Afghanistan pallets on politics
of modernization 1882 1946 written
chapters and other things on armenian
history and reworking one which was out
also this week islamic mosaic not a mono
late and lots of articles hundreds of
the articles on chapters how long did
you teach in San Francisco State San
Francisco still at was six years 62 to
68 even though I at [ __ ] 1860 also i
succeeded ironically david hogan who was
the first holocaust denier if a student
of david langer william Langer professor
at Harvard who wrote about a forced
enforced forced war that the Nazis were
not instigated a word but Britain and
Poland were responsible for the war yet
nervous breakdown and I succeeded him at
San Francisco State so from 6268 I
thought at San Francisco State in 1960
you wrote this in your book it was a
huge relief when Kennedy won yes one of
the few political statements i saw on
your book yes well it was fascinating
when i came 56 I were eyes on our button
because I had heard of Eisenhower but I
never heard of at least Stevenson later
1960 58 59 60 I heard the Eugene
McCarthy nominating Stevenson so
collected signatures for at least
evensen later kennedy and were in London
we waited all night to see who's going
to one and i was just enchanted and
transformed by his rhetoric and his
vision and youthfulness and so forth
about an idealistic america where
everybody had to chip in so if you're
right I've tried to be as a political as
possible because I wanted to be like my
french historian Gordon right present
the facts rather than try to come off
opinions as facts but in San Francisco
State you find yourself right now LOL
absolutely san francisco state when I
returned from soviet armenia in 1966 but
i had the one-year fellowship I was
faculty advisor to progressive Labour
Party the mouse and I got caught between
student movement it's been there many
witness was one of those electrifying
periods you had to be called communist
was to be like an insult you had to be
Trotsky at which was very respectable
you had to be SDS was respectable
progressive Labour Party was still young
democrats but then in addition you had
Young Republicans and others but it was
a exciting time and I was caught in
between struggle between SDS and
progressive Labour Party and as a matter
of fact my home was almost bombed at one
time we had to go for several days
spending berkeley in order to avert a
disaster go the head of political party
told me that we're afraid innocent
people will die they were nothing would
not worried about me other it would be
bad he advised me to call the police
which I thought maybe they were testing
me setting me up and so forth but it was
a fascinating period that so for two
years I was involved then I learned
through you to UCLA and in Texas how
long read the University of Texas for
years in your book you have a quote from
Ronnie Duggar yes when I Texas Monthly
the editor I want to read it and ask you
about some of this although he is
Dickensian Dickens could have known no
such man a wild Persian escapee from
some anonymous Armenian mortality
laughing all the time and full of genius
enjoying all the lies and foibles of the
American powerful but carrying mightily
for the human beings who in whose
endeavors he became part of Ronnie
Duggar rights he was one of the most
hypnotic tipsters of my journalistic
career what's he mean by that
in Texas when I went there I became the
head of Clan to honors college and
that's the time that the chairman of
board of regents of university of texas
franker we wanted Texas twix diversity
of Texas at Austin to expand the size of
its student body from 30,000 to
thirty-five forty thousand and faculty
opposed it and the PM person who was the
Dean of Faculty of Arts and Sciences
John Silver was not present of busting
University opposed it and so the
chairman decided to divide the arts and
science into four schools that way
nobody can say we cannot manage to have
all these students so I became along
with three four other people faculty
opposition against the trustees Ronnie
dog at that time was in charge of Texas
Monthly editor and there was Andi Emma
who's in charge of daily texan and few
others so all the news that came to them
they would meet periodically what's
going on and I would tell them this so
he was saying part of it was correct
part of it is not part of it all
speculation but he'd never seen such
elaborate tipster let's be he also rises
as in a play gregorian would be the one
who releases everyone's worst suspicions
by saying them out loud since everyone's
worst suspicions more or less
materialized he was in general right
talking fast laughing Headley he had a
faith in the country and the freedom of
the mind qualified by a devilish Lee
penetrating and mainly accurate
knowledge of the workings of selfish
power yes well if I had read my
Machiavelli avait thomas hobbes i had
also read lots of history so i never
underestimated ego self centeredness
selfishness and so forth so in texas I
always try to see what the power is
follow the money that's what we follow
ambition that was the other way and not
having ambition at that time I
I could easily analyze without being
involved as a matter fact one of the
reasons I left Texas when I came to find
out that I had power that I enjoyed
manipulating or opposing trustees
devising this strategy that tragedy
that's that strategy and then that's
what I decided that I was not the immune
to enjoying power or ambition that's one
of the reasons I live but I organize the
faculty their student body and so forth
so that's one of the reasons that I came
to distrust the kind of fever that catch
through that just because you can deny
people their ambition does not mean you
don't have power your power negative
power you can deny it but you don't
deliver it yet we still pretend that you
don't have power what year did you leave
the university of technology is 72 and
you went to the University pencil pencil
when and why well I wanted to teach in
Texas as a matter fact one of the great
things always has been the job I have
loved most has been teaching and as well
fact had I not received one of nation's
top ten teaching over CH harbison price
I would not have gone to Texas or from
Texas Pennsylvania co-teaching has been
always my forte so one of the reasons I
left for Texas from Texas for
Pennsylvania was to go teach it was
prestigious place Ivy League university
they were giving me what I wanted I
could teach history of Caucasus history
of Armenia European intellectual history
and South Asian history all by interest
because i joined PhD degree in history
and humanities after two years I was in
Pennsylvania that I was thrust upon
administrative position by President
Myerson became founding dean of faculty
of arts and sciences then later provost
but I always thought always correct my
own exams as a verdict today at the
Library of Congress one of my students
came from pin 10 days remind me who it
was and I knew not only was I knew his
great
you know which was fast and be like
erect my exam i wrote recommendations
and so so that's one of the reasons I
went to Penn not anticipating that I'll
be ending up as an administrator because
on your way to penn is according hear
from John Silver as you say is now
present of Boston University Boston
Boston University he was at the
University of Texas Vartan Gregorian is
one of the most imaginative and learned
men I know although he is a superb
teacher and a renowned historian his
most revealing quality is his
unpredictable and compelling sense of
humor a magic carpet that carries his
ideas and purposes to fruition with
remarkable frequency and minimal
opposition he has the innocence of a
baby the integrity and dedication of a
saint and the political skills of a
Talleyrand what does that mean well it
means all of them contradict each other
taladon does not have innocence of baby
but it means silber that I knew how to
deal with political power faculty power
and managed situations by organizing by
deflecting for example I mean there is
in the text when silver was fired as
dean at the University of Texas by the
Chairman told board and acting president
800 faculty shouting at each other they
all I compared them I said albanian
there's an Albanian saying where the car
falls all the butcher's come but as
faculty were shouting I got up as for
word as a hippie 9 Berliner now nobody
will say bin ein Berliner in the middle
of faculty stormy debate so they were
all stunned by all stopped and that was
my intention stop them in their tracks
or people will come and ask me that I
write in the book the dino veterinary
medicine came to ask me for a million
dollars but I became Provost I read his
proposal that's wonderful he said one of
the best things I have read but you're
not asking her enough how much they
asked said two million I said
so now i see asking equal to me now I'm
turning you down for two million i said
not 1,000,000 is to be very proud that
the sum is big enough and so forth but
its sense of humor how to use Huber in a
sense not to offend people to allow a
face-saving and at the same time to
bring them to your level that you don't
have money so they should not be
outrageous by asking you million cash
right away when they know you don't have
it and you know they know you don't have
it but you want to make them feel good
that's what he's referring all others we
learn in the book that you were offered
in a lot of presence ease of a lot of
different schools university of
california berkeley yes what year was at
1979 you said no i said no why i had
been president provost of university of
pennsylvania for only 18 months if i had
left the president already was lame duck
or announced his retirement my
predecessor provost had resigned the
dean of engineering had gone to lehigh
dino medicine had gone to Harvard and
hold all the deans 13 deans of the
university 12 Dean's unanimously at
support me faculty had support me as in
view of the fact that i'll provide some
stability and continuity the argument
that persuaded me to turn down was that
it's not good to accept something for 18
months and leave for better being that
weight very heavily especially when they
say in this country which means you as a
foreign-born may not realize but this is
the etiquette so i turned it down
without any conditions i stayed that
spin you are for New York University
presence though I was one of the
candidates I was over University of
Miami presidency Leo Florida in Florida
I was offered University of
Massachusetts presidency as a perfect
chairman of board and was the briar one
of our classmates at Stanford was
cheering but I always have been brought
up and the book deals with this with a
sense of duty and oublie
en outweighing your ambitions in 1995 i
was offered presence of Columbia but I
had not finished campaign for brown had
they waited one more year I would have
gone but it's unseemly to live in the
middle of campaign one IV for another IV
because of ambition and that's where my
grandmother's teaching and others come
across without my realizing things got
kind of nasty at the University of
Pennsylvania Oh unnecessarily I mean the
Provost I was provo which means what
chief academic officer number two at the
school number two how long were you that
in the year so about three years in a
year again would then went 90 in the
78th 280 so what happened how to get
nasty it got nasty because when i turned
berkeley down everybody thought i had an
agreement to be president of the rest of
pennsylvania there was no such agreement
but i had one condition that for
whatever reason you don't want me
because there is speculation you give me
advance noticed withdraw my name
otherwise i'll beat lame duck people
would say maybe the rest of your
Pennsylvania has something on him that
Berkeley did not know and that's the
only thing I thought they were I was
entitled to and they did not give me
that advance notice so I resigned in the
daily Pennsylvanian they said they wrote
about you Messiah of the University
saying that the trustees faculty and
students have turned to Gregorian to
restore stability and confidence he has
an impressive ability to bring people
together yeah where'd you get this I got
it by being a minority member and when I
grew up I got it by being an educator
that you have to bring people to
persuade them rather than dictate a
guide those temperamentally because I
hate conflict unnecessary conflict real
conflict I don't mind unnecessary
company based on stupidity and so forth
so so I got it because
iranian culture taught me one thing
there is a word adapt which means
comportment know how politeness
etiquette but we're all leos i was
brought up from childhood on don't allow
people to lose face dignity of people is
very important if you defeat somebody
don't gloat about it somehow if you have
one why go to the additional mild of
insulting people give them a way out for
captive dignity that you wanted to
resign you want to retire to their
family and so forth so I always have
been good at that from childhood on and
that was part of it that knowingly I
have not offended anyone to the best of
my knowledge along the way I came three
boys yes what are their names what is
via Vai valg is a chief sports writer in
st. Louis post-dispatch last year he was
named for Pulitzer Prize yes we
published two books he finished in the
rest of Pennsylvania they finished the
school of journalism University of
Missouri graduate school of journalism
and which one is he in this picture on
the left is far here in the middle is
Raffy who is the State Department he
finish University of Pennsylvania too he
became a with King's College London and
finished Johns Hopkins sighs here and
it's nine in the Bosnia and Kosovo desk
and the third one the third one on the
right this one is direct Gregorian he is
covering us the civil courts for the
York Post is also journalist to finish
Boston University and twenty school
along the way came the New York Public
Library yes and brown university yes New
York Public Library one has been one of
the great episodes of my life because I
I bet the
the chairman of search committee william
d build Adele had a Rockefeller Brothers
fund who took me to Andrew high school
head of type life and then Richard
Solomon and high school is the total
told poor fellow Richard Sullivan is the
other one and within 20 minutes they got
up and they said you are men we want you
to head new york public library and that
was nineteen eighty-one and i took it
because I was that naive I said if I
succeed they will say it's a miracle if
I fail it will be a great martyrdom
either way I could not was because the
cause was great tell us about them they
are probably like primer in size the
public library as for research libraries
and eighty-three branch libraries it's
one of the largest libraries in the
world and in this country and its
private they operated so public is in
the British sense it's private it's
funded by donors as well as governmental
and Prada sources city state and federal
sources 83 branch libraries primary
obligated our primary obligations of the
city and state in 1981 was that the
first gesture what kind of shape is it
in terrible shape as well fact my first
board meeting I attended on the agenda
was how to sell collections how to shut
some of the branches down and how to
charge admission fee and we'll pretend
that never occurred what was its budget
then its budget at that time I was 40
million was it today 200 plus how much
money did you have to raise at that time
raise four hundred million dollars to
restore the older library we restored
everything how'd you do it begging say
in the book you don't mind raising money
I don't mind trace money for a for a
cause
for me begging at the same time never
appealing to the vanity of people but
appealing to their civic duty I told the
new york public library does not need
class it gives class libraries our DNA
of our civilization libraries and
museums buildings don't give you
immortality cemeteries don't give you
immortality only thing kept giving
mortality is the book and the library
and the museum how I mean in New York
City this is a private institution yes
did he get government money at all yes
how much well several million from
National Endowment for Humanities for
federal money and so forth there is no
such thing as private institution
anybody in America nor public
institution public institutions now go
after private money and privateers go
after public money how big was your
board board was almost the 20-plus then
we made it 40 before we will go for a
campaign a name you see a lot in society
is brooke astor yes how old is she today
almost 100 200 hundred bump she always
shares one year I don't know why but
she's 120 years old wonderful woman
what's your story though I mean she got
into this big time with lots of money
her husband died a year of Vincent Astor
i think it was in the early 1950s and
said you're going to have fun with my
foundation and she had small foundation
of the personal fortune how much oh
maybe she spent 200 million dollars as
the foundation get two hundred million
dollars but with one condition that
every cause that she donates she had to
be c witness be with them assess before
she gave a second that the money had to
go to New York only because Astor made
the recent estimate his money in New
York different belongs to New York as
she's been remarkable person she's been
one of my great friends and one of my
great backers and we have a tremendous
time together is a quote that you have
in the book
first of all I'll read and ask you where
you got it they do you know it's what
i'm going to read probably but this is
from brooke astor be an optimist be
curious read every night don't meet the
same people all the time sooner or later
they become lazy boring and repeat
themselves don't be ascetic don't envy
or be jealous these sentiments are
corrosive and they diminish you spend
some time in solitude to reflect meet
different people young people travel and
if you are rich adhere to the Gospel of
quote The Joy of Giving unquote now
where did you get that from mrs. Astor
herself well she say why do you think I
said it become very good friends I said
tell me about the secrets of your
longevity and those are the words that
she uttered how do you remember that
though I put it down without went home
and I had two three speeches i gave i
told that her presence of public several
of them she also said i read
unfortunately to repeat some of these
things nowadays but the most important
thing that struck me as origional was
don't be the same people we become very
lazy have shorthand remember that thing
and then it takes the age of seconds at
every night read for an hour or what
just replenish your mind and be very
curious other parties that you gave are
not the same people she likes to be with
been with young and younger people
running all be one evening as a matter
of fact we went to a party I won't
mention names of the people because
they're still alive oh my god said that
one is bent look at that one is so old
let's get out of here and there were 70
65 and she was 19 so until age 90 she
used to dance but I went to dance with
her and so we're very close and several
times that I visitor I made a repeat
some of these things just to be sure
that I got it right and so not to meet
the same people but also not
be envious and she'll tell today also
I've never had a facelift that's night
as that and if you have basically of
your vein it means I've never had a
facelift she says because that also sign
of vanity what year did you go to brown
brown I went 1988 why I got tired of
fundraising and also became I was afraid
of hubris that I could do everything you
come to believe their 40 volumes of
articles written about Andrew high
schools and my tenure and mrs. Astor's
at the library every day New York Times
covered every day what happened at the
library and I paid great tribute to
approval you know give Arthur gilben
others in the ER at primary and yeah
they supported it so suddenly they said
you can do it you can do it but I got
very tired asking for money and becoming
a social butterfly I want to go back to
university and I did were you given the
presidency out of the box right away no
I had two choices three choices vamos
MacArthur Foundation second one was in
the west of Michigan at Ann Arbor and
third one was brown I took brown because
it was private it was small also because
of dick Sullivan was a chairman of board
of new york public library was
chancellor of Brown University at the
time how big is brown 7500 students 580
of faculty and the medical school a
couple of hundred others at junk back
there's more in the book on brown but we
are running out of time it's not what I
asked you when you left there and why
you went to Carnegie the carnegie
corporation as a rule which is very good
question as a rule I always decided I
will stay minimum five maximum 10 but no
more than that and that's another advice
or Brooks you become stale you let the
routine govern you when I gave the same
speech
twice I get very bored today as a matter
of fact library of congress i said this
speech I gave today I said I've done it
once in your public library i'm bored
with it because i have to be looking
forward so that's what one of the
reasons i like to replant myself as a
matter of fact I have Gabrielle Garcia
Marquez in love in the Time of Cholera
says people are not born once a parole
when their mothers gave birth to them
but throughout their life they give
rebirth to themselves and my life has
been one of those every now and then I
give renew myself give rebirth myself in
order to keep my attention and my
curiosity and my excitement on life you
don't tell us in the book how you gave
the five hundred million dollars of
water annenberg away ah that's another
value if you choose it all gone it's all
gone committed why did he get why did he
ask you to give it away because he
trusted my judgment I was his friend I
never solicited him ever for any cause
so when he was criticized by Wall Street
Journal and some others what have what
has he done for public sector because
everything had done for private sector
he decided to do something for public
sector public education so he called the
David currents it was former head of
Xerox good friend of his and then few
others and then I was his friend for
since 1972 from Penn and he called me he
said I want you to hit the ground and
running so there was no time to study
and so forth because he wanted to go
into most complex things most difficult
things urban education not to go to a
fellowship scholarship which were easy
but he wanted me to the Detroit New York
Los Angeles Chicago all the major
problem areas and come up with building
bipartisan coalition's which I did on
his behalf and every reporter reformer
whether on the left
the right where the solution is that we
have supported not show the nation that
all solutions have been tested so at the
time I said if we come up with the fifty
percent of success story i'll be very
happy because it took lots of time to do
this but one thing he did succeed he put
education as number one item on nation's
agenda to have a republican conservative
republican to give the largest gift
public sector was an amazing act at the
time and to do it from White House a
Democratic president also because you
said in this there is no Democrats not
Republicans American public education
can not be held hostage we have to help
it so because of friendship and he also
send me when I became president of Brown
assembly two million because he had seen
a picture of mine in Newsweek I'm in
Business Week so that's the best picture
I have seen therefore we celebrate our
friendship and closed his two million
with which I established two chairs in
his honor one for retirees you have to
be retired person in order to be able to
have that chair if folks want the
details are going to have to read the
road to home this is what the cover look
looks like and our guest has been Vartan
Gregorian thank you very much for Jack
you very much Brian